Justice League may have been released
almost two years ago back in November
2017 but there's still plenty of
mystique surrounding the film director
Zack Snyder suddenly left Justice League
in May 2017 as post-production was about
to start deciding to stay home and
support his family after the death of
his daughter autumn into the void
stepped Avengers director Joss Whedon to
complete the film but according to those
who worked the movie he didn't exactly
pick up where Snyder left off making
drastic changes to the final product the
theatrical version of Justice League
resulted in mixed reviews but then came
hope for DC fans in the form of the news
flash that Snyder
despite his departure from the film
before completion still has his version
of Justice League that juicy little
tidbit had DC fans tongues wagging eager
to see what has been dubbed the Snyder
cut it's been a long time waiting for an
update of that cut and while it seems
increasingly unlikely the cut will ever
be released to the public there are some
in higher circles who have been lucky
enough to lay eyes on it
Jason Momoa who starred in Justice
League as the underwater superhero
Aquaman is one of that very elite group
Touma moas Instagram followers this is
old news because the Aquaman star
revealed back in August that the Snyder
cut was quote sick earlier this month
Momoa was speaking to mtv news Josh
Horowitz when he revealed maybe a bit
more than Warner Brothers executives
will be pleased with when Horowitz
brought up a past comment Momoa made
about the Snyder cut of Justice League
that being yeah I need to see that Momoa
dropped this bombshell yeah absolutely
but I have seen it so you've seen you'd
I've seen Aesthetica so those Snyder
left Justice League before post
production started Momoa seemed to hint
that Snyder may in fact have completed
his original version for the belt
effects at all after Momoa revealed he's
already seen the Snyder cut Horowitz
posed the question so what does that
what does that mean because the effects
aren't done like you can just say you've
seen his assemblage of footage and
alternate takes only four Momoa to quit
back that already things I couldn't
finish a-- the actor didn't let too much
slip though following with a quick
next question when Horowitz tried to get
confirmation about whether the Snyder
cut is fully edited despite the secrecy
surrounding the cut Momoa does feel that
it's worth making it available to the
public
Momoa is also hoping his statements
don't get him fired from Aquaman 2 the
sequel to his surprise smash hit
standalone from December 2018 let's
recap the final cut of Justice League
that was ultimately released to the
public in November 2017 wasn't very well
received with fans saying they could
clearly see where one directors vision
ended and the others began according to
The Wrap the incomplete look of Justice
League spurred an Insider to give it the
unfortunate description of a
Frankenstein film sources with knowledge
of the production have also revealed
that approximately 30 minutes of the
released film was actually directed by
Whedon replacing 30 minutes of filming
done by Snyder the first time around
that doesn't include footage shot by
Snyder that Whedon edited into a
completely different context for the
final product Whedon who is known for
his work in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe managed to disappoint DC fans
as he tried to incorporate misplaced
humor into an altogether darker universe
followers of the franchise are thrilled
there's another version of Justice
League and have been calling desperately
for it to be released the hashtag
released the Snyder cut has been doing
the rounds on social media with a
petition started as early as the film's
release in November 2017 and efforts
only amped up after Momoa confirmed its
existence in October 2018 Momoa z'
recent remarks to mtv news only add fuel
to this ever burning fire a fire which
has also been stoked by the likes of
Justice League cinematographer Fabian
Wagner and Jesse Eisenberg and ray
Fisher the actors who portrayed Lex
Luthor and cyborg respectively all have
stated that they'd like to see the
Snyder cut released to the public
though Warner Brothers is remaining
tight-lipped at this stage about the
Snyder cut of Justice League the
excitement surrounding it sure isn't
dying down with little details being
leaked here and there the studio might
one day be persuaded to let the heroes
loose as they were originally intended
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
one
[Music]